bonsoir à vous bon soir avant
novelli qui est alexis poulain alors
j'ai commencé par vous et alexis poulain
les députés ont adopté l'extension du
pass sanitaires à l'aube au terme de
longues heures de débats intenses donc
au forceps
est ce que c'est un bon ou un mauvais
signe ça pourra le gouvernement déjà un
mauvais signe parce qu'il ya eu
énormément d'amendements que le débat
parlementaire a été sabotée par cette
majorité qui veut passer en force comme
à chaque fois
et puis il y aura la discussion au sénat
et puis il y aura le conseil
constitutionnel saisi par le premier
ministre qui prévoit déjà l'amendement
ou l'adaptation d'une loi qui est
inadaptable qui est totalement indigne
par rapport aux lois que ceux qui sont
celles de la république égalité liberté
fraternité et aux lois qui sont les
règles qui régissent en fait notre notre
vivre ensemble peu importe l'importance
de cette crise sanitaire
aujourd'hui on a l'impression qu'elle
est un prétexte finalement pour avancer
des lois liberticides pour avancer des
les empêchements de certains français
parce qu' une des questions que les
soignants perdre leur travail s'ils ne
sont pas vaccinés que certains perdent
leur travail s'ils ne sont pas vaccinés
ont fait fi du droit du travail ont fait
fi finalement de la solidarité qui
devrait être finalement le ciment après
cette crise sanitaire majeure le monde
d'après que nous propose emmanuel macron
était d'hier s'est fait pousser plus
loin la logique néolibérale pousser plus
loin la compétition de tous contre tous
est montré du doigt les non vaccinés
ceux qui ne veulent pas rentrer dans
cette ce jeu finalement de de renouveau
alors qu' il faudrait peut-être
réfléchir sur notre modèle de société et
faire que la solidarité soit au centre
c'est tout l'un vertes qui se joue on a
quand même
olivier ferrand un ministre de la santé
et des solidarités qui est là pour
casser des familles pour empêcher que
l'on puisse aller voir les malades à
l'hôpital si on n'est pas vacciner si on
n'a pas notre passe-temps terrain c'est
lundi c'est inacceptable arnaud
benedetti est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec alexis blanc lorsqu'il dit que tout
est prétexte finalement à des lois
liberticides
il est clair qu'on est dans une forme de
basculement qui ne voulait on met le
doigt dans un engrenage qui le sous
prétexte de crise sanitaire met à mal
notre architecture est une architecture
l'on pense sur les principes qui sont
ceux qui le démocratie libérale
il ya deux valeurs j'ai tiré trois
valeurs qui sont au frontispice de la
république qui sont la liberté on
entrave la liberté de mouvement on a
déjà vu mais on travaille de manière
encore plus forte que par le passé bien
évidemment on exclut la question du
confinement
on met à mal le principe d'égalité
puisque on va finalement à sortir la
possibilité de circuler à un état qui
est un état sanitaire dont on dévoile en
plus les données ce qui pose un problème
de confidentialité de secret médical
et si l'on on prend comme référence la
dernière valeur du front républicain qui
est celui de la fraternité il est clair
que on voit bien que tout ce qui
constitue finalement une société qui est
humaine qui permet malgré les
difficultés aux gens de pouvoir vivre
ensemble de cette société profondément
fracturé je crois qu'il ya en effet
aujourd'hui un vrai problème de ce côté
là et que ce qui est le plus surprenant
c'est que ce teta y signer a du mal à
accéder à l'espace public alors certains
étaient mobilisation qui se sont
déroulées le week-end dernier dans la
tourbe qui vont se dérouler samedi des
parlementaires et parfois même des
parlementaires de la majorité
du coup le le signal et je pense
notamment aux députés de de paris
monsieur a contraint qui ont pris des
positions qui sont des positions plus
qu'à me semble-t-il de bon sens par
rapport à ceux à ce texte
mais on voit qu'il ya une difficulté à
faire émerger un tuyau est une
problématique qui est essentiel parce
que elles touchent au fondement même de
notre régime est sa véritable inquiétude
l'accord de ce point de vue là est un
des pays qui va le plus loin dans
l'extension face au leader il ya un
problème de proportionnalité par rapport
aux finalités par rapport aux objectifs
le conseil d'état il a été formulé quand
même extrêmement surprenants voix
extrêmement déçu table puisque
d'ailleurs il est contradictoire par
rapport à la vie que lui même a défendu
le 6 juillet on voit qu'il ya quelque
chose en tout cas je crois réellement se
produire
justement vous l'avez dire tous les deux
ce coup de théâtre le basque est
obligatoire dans les hôpitaux dans les
ehpad sauf dans les urgences
heureusement on va dire et vous la vidéo
si demain il y aura non il ya eu des
manifestations et demain on s'attend
encore à des manifestations assez dur
notamment à paris c'est vrai que cette
mesure de rendre obligatoire le passe
dans les hôpitaux les ehpad ça peut être
perçu comme un durcissement clairement
de la part du gouvernement
alexis poulain mais c'est pas un
durcissement c'est que depuis le début
de cette crise en mars 2020 on a affaire
à des gens qui sont en capacité et de
décisions au pouvoir et qui sont
incapables de gérer une crise de cette
ampleur
on a affaire à des gens qui sont sidérés
qui réagissent dans l'immédiateté qui
demandent des sondages pour savoir quels
doivent être leur décision si elle
pourrait être acceptée ou non et qui
finalement décide avec un agenda qui
n'est pas en plus sanitaire qui est
derrière de dire il faut refaire la
réforme des retraites il faut refaire la
réforme de l'assurance chômage
il faut continuer à casser le droit
social et cas c'est même le droit du
travail tout ça une rapidité inouïe sans
jamais réfléchir sur la portée
philosophique de philosophie politique
de ses choix
qu'est ce que c'est que la république
française ces gens là ne se pose pas la
question et je veux m'en pense même
qu'il s'en fiche c'est là où c'est
terrible c'est que pour eux à régime ou
un autre et que nous allons rentrer dans
un régime de biosurveillance de techno
surveillance et que pour eux c'est un
mal pour un bien que c'est pas grave que
finalement moins de liberté pour plus de
sécurité ce n'est pas plus mal
mais ce qu'il faut voir c'est que plus
on rogne les libertés non non non et y'a
rien qui va en réalité dans les lois qui
sont votées ce soir hier et qui vont
être discuté au sénat les discussions à
l'assemblée nationale était indigne sur
le fait de simplement mettre à la rue
des gens parce qu'ils n'ont pas le
passeport vaccinale comme a été dit par
monsieur mégarde alain qui
et que oui c'était un passeport
solitaire c'est un passeport vaccinale
finalement donc si les gens refusent par
principe en disant je ne sais pas
j'attends de voir ce que ce que fait ce
produit j'attends de voir aussi comment
fonctionne cette politique sanitaire si
elle fonctionne ou non là on force les
gens dans un monde qui n'a rien à voir
avec un monde salutaire mais qui est un
monde de contrôle total et de
biocontrôle c'est inacceptable
philosophiquement politiquement parlant
et je crois que on a affaire là un
personnel politique indigne parce qu'il
n'est pas à la hauteur de la mission qui
elle vient représenter le peuple
français
on a affaire à des gens qui aujourd'hui
discute de sujets qui n'ont rien à voir
avec la crise sanitaire
basé sur des extrapolations ou les
cabinets de conseil mène la danse et où
un président est dépassé par ces
situations c'est vrai que arnaud
vénalité les français vont avoir du mal
à comprendre en fait les décisions qui
sont prises on l'a vu dans le sujet tout
à l'heure concernant les les boîtes de
nuit les premiers kloster apparaissent
dans les boîtes de nuit qui ont été sont
et lieux qui ont été soumis donc au
pastel iter en premier est-ce que ça se
passait ni terre finalement il fait
oublier les la nécessité d'adopter
toujours et encore les mesures barrières
parce que le gouvernement aussi fait
fausse route et ne le rappelle pas
suffisamment moi je crois que surtout ça
démontre que on rêve que depuis le début
de crise dans une forme d'un préparation
rapport à l'évolution de la situation
quelle qu'elle soit je rappelle que
seulement il y à un mois et demi c'était
moi tu es nous avions toute une séquence
de communication tout as touring et
ligne de l'exécutif qui était celui des
jours heureux et de la sortie de ville
les problèmes de fond dans cette ville
n'ont jamais été réglé les problèmes de
fond c'est quoi et réarmer l'hôpital
pour faire face notamment à l'affût
d'éventuels de malades
oh ça c'est un sujet récurrent dont on
ne parle d'ailleurs pratiquement plus
aujourd'hui dans le débat public
pour aulas vous avez un petit d'un
exemple qui est un exemple très parlant
d'un préparation donc la difficulté
aujourd'hui de l'exécutif en essaie de
répondre en urgence face à l'émergence
d'un variant le variant delta
un lent très lent qu'on pouvait très
bien se fermer les frontières on savait
très bien qu'il ya quelques il ya encore
quelques semaines nous avions osé vol
qui arrivait directement atteindre sans
que cela pose la moindre difficulté donc
toutes les mesures d'anticipation qui
permettrait aujourd'hui d'une certaine
manière de mieux d'affronter d'âcre ils
ne sont jamais pris par l'exécutif en
temps et en heure et donc à partir de ce
à partir de ce constat qu'est ce que
pelé l'exécutif il bureaucratique
toujours plus sa gestion c'est à dire
que il impose un contrôle social que
quand même un contrôle social dont on
doit poser la question dans un régime
qui était résident pour qu il le
rappeler encore qui est un régime
libéral
donc je pense qu'on met le doigt dans un
engrenage c'est en effet un engrenage
que ce point de vue là me paraît en tout
cas pour le moins dangereux
je les étudie le projet de loi et qui
prône plus de souplesse par ailleurs
avec ses points est ce que vous pensez
vous que les choses vont aller dans un
autre sens avec le sénat mais j'espère
j'espère que les sénateurs seront
davantage connectée au pays ils vont
comprendre que si on continue dans cette
logique ce de techno contrôle sanitaire
terrible alors on va mettre à la porte
de nombreux français qui travaillent qui
souhaitent travailler
regardez déjà les cinémas ont vu leur
baisse la fréquentation de leurs salles
baissé de je ne sais pas quand même pour
cent les salles de spectacle c'est la
même chose et dès le 1er août les
restaurants vont mettre la clé sous la
porte
donc le cdas si il est logique s'il
connaît les français ce que ne font pas
la réplique en marche puisqu'il ne
connaissent pas ce pays
eh bien ils vont comprendre que les
travailleurs de ce pays ceux qui ont des
commerces ceux qui accueillent du public
eh bien on besoin de travailler elle ne
peut pas continuer comme ça aujourd'hui
toute cette gestion de crise et depuis
le début est un fiasco mais terrible de
la république en marche 2 emmanuel
macron ce président qui a centralisé
tout sur lui avec ses conseils de
défense et à chaque fois la faune aux
biens aux français c'est les français
qui ce responsable partie ils ne sont
pas responsables justement ils ont fait
n'importe quoi c'est eux qui ont des
confiné enfin quand même notre premier
ministre et jean castex était le
monsieur recharge finement l'an dernier
inquiète spots total
voilà le premier ministre et que fait-il
il remet encore une fois la faute sur le
dos des français
c'est inacceptable insupportable des
mairies de sa durée en conséquence juste
rapidement demain à ce qu'il faut
s'attendre
ça va ça risque d'être chaud demain dans
la rue peut-être avec des violences
aussi à un nouveau cycle de violence
dans la rue
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que on
voit bien qu'il y ait un processus
d'oxydation qui d'ailleurs a surpris
l'exécutif qui est en train de se mettre
en place et qui ne correspond pas à la
réalité sondagière la vérité c'est que
aujourd'hui l'exécutif se base sur
quelques chantage sur lequel dayori
tirer beaucoup pas dire pour d'une
certaine manière légitimer son action
politique
il est confronté de fait à un risque de
si les jaunes isation vous permettez ce
néologisme de cette mobilisation dans
les semaines qui viennent
merci beaucoup à vous arnaud benetti
rédacteur en chef de la revue politique
et parlementaire merci à vous également
alexis poulain éditorialistes